in this house they call them the bars of
gold and Steph needs a lot of them she's
got two kids and a coffee trailer
business that she runs around East
Yorkshire I do a lot of baking so I go
through a lot of butter and like this is
now two pound which is a lot more
expensive than it used to be and
obviously I'm not just using one a week
I'm using quite a lot so
yeah frustrating very frustrating yeah
we all know this is happening but it's
here where they see what it's doing
Two Rivers Community pantry is a
discount food scheme in ghoul
Sam and her daughter Caitlin were
shopping here for the first time pasta
definitely that's gonna like big style
um
milk bread everything every all your
basic stuff
it's hard work going and doing a food
shop now you can't just put shove stuff
in Trolley you've got to actually think
about it
you're working all out as you go along
yeah yeah definitely so our shopping
habits are changing because we've been
priced out of normality
people at the lower end of the income
Spectrum are reporting that they are
really having difficulty making ends
meet particularly those people with
prepayment meters or or people with
disabilities or people who are private
renters
the big supermarkets say they are trying
to offer even better value but for so
many families including those in work
the sums do not add up it is across the
country it's not just specific to Google
it's all over and is there a way out of
it
at the moment I can't see it hopefully
Rishi will do something about it and
there will be a way out of it
but at the moment I can't see what's
going to change in the very near future
the demand at the pantry has seen the
money they take double in the past month
in any other shop that would be good but
here it signals that something is badly
wrong
Tom Parmenter Sky News in East Yorkshire